as the supreme court considers dumping
roe versus wade abortion fanatics on the
left prepare to go crazy oh macron hits
new york and joe biden tries to brag
about his economic success with the
world's dumbest chart i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first this holiday season you're
probably not sleeping enough but here's
the thing you can get yourself a holiday
gift or a friend a holiday gift and give
them the gift of magical magical sleep
i'm talking about a helix sleep mattress
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for somebody else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep everybody is unique helix knows
that they have several different
mattress models to choose from they have
soft medium and firm mattresses mattress
is great for cooling you down if you
sleep hot mattress is great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus size mattress
for plus size sleepers so if you are
looking for a mattress you take the quiz
you order the mattress you match to the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again they've got
a 10-year warranty you can try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll pick it
up for you if you don't love it but you
will helix even has financing options
and flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away my wife
and i have a helix sleep mattress
customized just for us it is both firm
and breathable it is exactly what we are
looking for just go to helixleep.com ben
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to that customized
mattress get the best sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at
helixleep.com so good i already used it
for my parents helix again
helixsleep.com
ben alrighty so the supreme court is
currently considering whether to
overrule roe versus wade i actually
think that what the supreme court is
likely to do in this particular case is
uphold the mississippi law that would
essentially bar abortion after the 15th
week i don't think they're going to
overrule versus wade i think you're
going to end up with a split decision in
planned parenthood versus casey you
really never ended up with a solid
majority decision you had a majority for
certain principles and then you had four
justices voting for one thing and four
justices voting for another thing i
think that what emerges from this case
is likely to be a mess i think that it
is not going to be something as clear as
even viability which is an unclear and
stupid standard i think it'll be less
clear than that i don't think it's going
to be the trimester framework of roe vs
wade i i don't know what it's going to
be i do think that we are optimistic on
the pro-life side if we think that roe
vs wade is going to be completely
overturned even though that ought to be
the outcome here and here's the thing
even if roe versus wade is overturned
the law in new york is not going to be
the same as the law in mississippi and
everybody who studies law understands
this because that was the case before
roe versus wade california had some
pretty liberal abortion laws new york
had some pretty liberal abortion laws
and texas had some pretty strict
abortion laws before roe versus wade
went into place nonetheless the fact
that the supreme court is now
considering the possibility of
disestablishing a constitutional right
to abortion which again does not exist
it was made up out of whole cloth and an
entire line of cases stretching all the
way back to griswold through
v baird all the way up through planned
parenthood versus casey that supposed
constitutional right to abortion was
made up directly out of the colons of
supreme court justices who had political
leanings in favor of a pro-choice
position
[Music]
even if it were overruled if if ladies
want to get abortions all they have to
do is not be in texas and they could go
over the over the border to mexico and
presumably they'd be able to get an
abortion there they'd go over to
california get an abortion there listen
i would prefer a nationwide regime
wherein no one can get an abortion
except in cases where the mother's life
is in danger but
that's not the way the federalist system
works and because of that that means
that there will be state differences in
how abortion law is applied but the left
is losing it they are losing it and the
reason they're losing it is because once
you remove the constitutional right to
abortion once you say that there is no
constitutional right to abortion this
brings back into play the rules of
nature and this is something that the
left has been fighting very hard as i
pointed out yesterday for the left
equality of outcome is the only metric
of success in a society and there are
certain natural barriers to equality of
outcome in every arena of life and some
people are taller some people are
shorter some people are dumber some
people are smarter one of the great
obstacles to equality of outcome in life
are physical differences between men and
women men and women do not operate the
same way their bodies do not operate the
same way and women very often make
choices that are dependent on their
ability to bear and rear children
and they they like those choices for the
most part this has been the greatest
superpower of women since time
immemorial is that women are capable of
bearing children and then feeding the
children with their own body and
bringing those children up
and by the way when women are given the
opportunity to
take time off from the workforce to
spend time with children they are far
more likely to do so than fathers are
okay so the the attempt to
crack down on motherhood which has been
an aspect of the far left has now taken
over the entire left so the left used to
say that abortion used to be it should
be rare in in very circumscribed cases
because you know it's really a bad thing
and you need to allow it to be legal
because you never know something really
bad could happen you might need an
abortion right that used to be the case
now it is a centralized aspect of
femininity that abortion be there it is
central to womanhood that you'd be able
to terminate your pregnancy
this is a very different position than
the position that the left used to hold
even as late as the 1990s pretty
consistently now the position is that in
order for women to achieve the same
outcomes as men women have to be able to
for any reason
rid their bodies of a of a human life
with potential
and so the fact that the supreme court
is now considering
getting rid of the quote-unquote
constitutional right to abortion
means that the left has lost its mind
and um and they're going to spout
nonsense and craziness and and make
arguments that that have no internal
logic to them and this is what happened
all day yesterday all day yesterday you
got from the media just the craziest
positions
unsustainable illogical insane immoral
positions being spouted by the left on a
regular basis okay so one of the
questions that you should be asking
yourself when it comes to the left
perspective on abortion
is why they feel this way about abortion
particularly it's kind of strange so if
you go back and you read early margaret
sanger who was the founder of planned
parenthood she was quite anti-abortion
margaret tanger thought that it was a
threat to human life abortion margaret
sanger was in favor of contraception she
was in favor of birth control but
abortion as a method of birth control is
something that was opposed by even wild
leftists in the 1920s 1930s when
margaret sanger was a prominent
political figure in the united states
and birth control is now widely
available in the united states it's
universally available in the united
states it is not difficult to obtain
birth control in fact the west has
gotten so good at birth control that we
are depopulating ourselves out of
existence every western country with the
exception of georgia
in europe and israel has a below
replacement rate population problem and
we are producing fewer children than
there are parents in the population in
order to reproduce at replacement rates
you have to have at least 2.1 children
per family right now most of the west is
at 1.7 1.8 nearly 1.3
right so we're very good at avoiding
having babies as it turns out so why
exactly is abortion such a necessity
and the answer is because in order for
the left to maintain that equality of
outcome is the only thing that matters
they have to say that every step along
the way the only thing that matters is
the outcome for the woman not the
outcome for the baby they have to say
that for ev every step of the way right
they cannot limit the principle to birth
control
the obligation for a woman
it never exists according to the left
because if there's an obligation for a
woman that a man does not have it's
unfair even if that obligation was
created by basic mammalian biology and
so you end up with the specter of people
on the left arguing that pregnancy
itself is some sort of enemy it's an
obstacle to be overcome because after
all women can get pregnant but men
cannot
although the left takes a conflicting
position about this now they say the men
can get pregnant so this really should
obviate the abortion debate really
because if the left idea is that
pregnancy is an inherent bad because it
makes men and women fundamentally
unequal well problem solved men can get
pregnant now and women can have balls
according to most of the left
but they get rid of that argument the
minute that it becomes inconvenient
because after all it just happens to be
a biological fact that only women can
get pregnant of course and they have to
acknowledge that in the context of
abortion it's weird how fast that
language pregnant people went away and
no more chest feeding around here right
that lasted purely as long as we were
attempting to castigate republicans as
bigots but the minute we're talking
about abortion it's back to pregnant
women and only women should have an
opinion on abortion and only women can
get pregnant okay so we begin yesterday
with nancy pelosi nancy pelosi seems to
it is amazing to hear the party of
science declare that babies in the womb
don't exist they just don't exist now my
sister
sent me an ultrasound of her kid in the
womb yesterday my sister classically
abby up in virginia she sent me a
picture of her ultrasound and it's a 3d
ultrasound
that is a baby my friends okay we are
talking about like a full face i can see
the features of the baby's face i know
that she that the baby looks like my uh
my sister and my sister's husband right
i can see all of it that is a baby it is
not a cluster of cells it is not a
meaningless
potential human life it is none of those
things but the left tries to claim that
the reason they are pro-abortion is
because they are pro-science which is a
complete lie so here's nancy pelosi
lecturing us on the birds and the bees
which by the way i gotta tell you nancy
pelosi lecturing people on the birds and
the bees
might end the practice of sex
permanently like no one should be forced
to watch this clip because no one will
ever want to have sex again after
listening to nancy pelosi talk about
going after it
from what they have said about not
respecting um precedents at star
decisions all of that
uh is troubling and what they have said
about sometimes i think they need a
session in birds and the bees
through some of the kinds of statements
that they make
i say that is mother five
okay and this has become a commonplace
row sort of wrote talking point on the
left
is that people who are pro-life need a
need and explainer on sex
i'm pretty sure you guys need the
explainer on sex because you seem to
think that sex and pregnancy are
completely disconnected
well that's not the way it works you
don't catch a pregnancy you're not just
in a room like covid and you're five
feet away from somebody for 15 minutes
and magically you're pregnant that's not
the way any of this works nor typically
do people slip and fall on penises and
randomly get pregnant that's not how
that works either so nope
actually it turns out that for all of
human history and again all of mammalian
history
sex has led to pregnancy
it is only since the 1960s that we've
been able to scientifically disconnect
sex from pregnancy in any sort of
consistent way
i mean if you go all the way back to the
1940s for example what you will see is
that the plurality of marriages in the
united states happened
post-pregnancy
meaning that there were a lot of
seven-month babies happening in the
1940s a lot of shotgun marriages
happening because sex was connected to
pregnancy as it always has been and for
most of the world still is by the way
and it's only in the west that we've
been able to scientifically uncouple sex
from pregnancy i think in many ways for
a great moral detriment
but then it's not just nancy pelosi
lecturing us about how sex works it's
joy behar again i got to say the the
people who are being brought forth by
the democrats to lecture americans on
how sex works
um
it's
disturbing
and uh
whatever is the opposite of a turn on
this would be it right here
it's a very interesting schism that goes
on here because on the one hand
sex sells everywhere i mean you can't
see an aspirin commercial without
somebody having sex you cannot turn on
any program especially on streaming
where people are having this
there's soft porn everywhere now they
encourage all of that it sells
everything sex sells and yet when it
comes to the reality of pregnancy
this particular group of people on the
right in this country and these
religious zealots do not understand the
reality of what happens when you have
sex
wait i'm confused maybe you don't
understand the reality of what happens
when you have sex which is the
possibility of pregnancy
always and forever unless you tie your
tubes
so like i'm just i have to say i'm
absolutely bewildered by the perspective
of the left that people on the right
don't understand sex because they
believe in human life in the womb
i'm pretty sure you guys don't
understand sex because it seems like you
think that sex is basically like kissing
and that it doesn't transmit
any sort of risk of pregnancy sex
or that the product of sex the natural
product of sex by the way the entire
evolutionary biology reason that sex
exists okay sex does not exist as an
evolutionary biology biological
phenomenon predominantly in order that
people can stimulate each other's nerve
endings it exists predominantly as an
evolutionary biological phenomenon in
order for the procreation of species
that that is the dominant biological
drive right that is that is why that is
there okay and
how they say that
these are the people who are lecturing
us on sex
seriously
hey really
okay okay so that that's an argument
they've been attempting to trot out
that's not even the worst argument on
the view right whoopi goldberg made the
worst argument on the view yesterday
and again being lectured by the likes of
nancy pelosi joy behar and whoopi
goldberg on sex
man no one in this country is ever going
to have sex again if these clips are too
widely viewed
but we'll get to that in just a moment
first let us talk about your home
insurance okay so here is the deal
winter is approaching now is a time to
get your property cold weather ready by
making sure you have the right insurance
coverage policy genius can help you get
the home insurance you need and they can
bundle it with auto coverage so that you
can save money head on over to
policygenius.com shapirohome answer a
few questions about yourself and your
property policy genius will show you
price estimates for policies that fit
your search and help you understand your
options the policy genius team can look
for ways to save you more money if they
find a better rate than what you're
paying right now they'll switch you over
for free policy genius has saved
customers an average of one thousand two
hundred fifty dollars per year over what
they were paying for home and auto
insurance their licensed experts will
help you understand your options and
apply for a policy the policy genius
team works for you not the insurance
companies
you can trust them to offer unbiased
help and advocate for you at every step
until you are covered policy genius
doesn't add on extra fees or sell your
information to third parties they have
thousands of five star reviews across
trustpilot and google since 2014 policy
genius has helped over 30 million people
shop for insurance so
head on over to policygenius.com
shapirohome to get your free home and
auto insurance quotes see how much you
could save that's policy genius.com
shapiro home okay so the weakness of the
so-called pro-choice position it's
extremely weak especially considering
the possibility of contraception via
birth control and so argument number one
is conservatives somehow don't
understand sex and the people who make
that argument are people who simply do
not seem to understand that sex and
procreation are necessarily intertwined
and in fact are part of the same act
okay and then you have the argument that
only women should speak on abortion
which is an idiotic argument especially
again coming from the same people who
say that women can have balls and men
can have uteruses i i you cannot
simultaneously hold the position that
trans men are men trans women are women
and also that only biological women get
to have an opinion on abortion those are
not consistent positions you cannot hold
them they are mutually exclusive
okay but in in left world you can hold
whatever positions you want
they are the kama sutra of political
positions any position you want any time
here is whoopi goldberg lecturing us all
on why only women should be able to
speak about abortion even this makes no
sense
do any of you men
have any eggs or the possibility of
carrying a fetus how dare you talk about
what a fetus wants you have no idea
now i'm i'm fine if you disagree with
abortion i have no problem with that my
problem comes when you tell me
what i need to do with my doctor and my
family how dare you how dare you
okay um i i've noticed that you guys
don't have the same live and let live
approach to any other issue in american
life
love to very live and let live when it
comes to abortion i don't care if you
have a baby but you can't tell me
whether i can kill my baby in the womb
also you need to bake that cake for that
gay couple right the hell now okay
so let's begin with the conflicts in
this clip because it really is
indicative of how self-defeating the
left position is on these things so
again she begins with the proposition
with the proposition that men do not
have eggs the entire left now believes
that men have eggs
right there some some men get pregnant
right trans men are men right the clappy
hand emoji hey then my favorite is that
she just switches right over into
if you're not a woman how can you speak
for the fetus
okay we're gonna stop you right there
whoopi because
you're an idiot
all of us have been fetuses i have been
a fetus you have been a fetus would be
goldberg it turns out every single human
living on earth has at one point been a
fetus male
female all of the three hundred thousand
two hundred
genders all of us have been fetuses at
some point so all of us
could have a perspective on what a fetus
would want also i don't feel like it's
such an assumption as to what the fetus
wants
i i will grant you that i may not know
what a fetus might want in terms of say
food taste but i feel like a baseline
thing a fetus doesn't want is to have
somebody chop their head up in the womb
and suck them into a sink i have a
feeling that's like that seems like a
real easy one
mainly because i'm not sure that any
living creature is super interested in
having somebody jab a syringe into them
and pump poison into their veins so that
they die and then are flushed down the
toilet i'm pretty sure there are not a
lot of living creatures at all who are
interested in that so i don't think i
have to be a woman to understand what a
fetus wants i think all i have to be is
a baseline human being with a shred of
decency to understand what a fetus wants
again not to have your body chopped up
would be like number that's not number
10 unless someone's like number one with
a bullet on the list
okay they don't have it it is just it is
just ire that's all they have they just
have rage at the world and rage at
biology and rage is the reality that
there are certain burdens to being a
woman that do not exist for men and one
of those burdens is and when i say
burden i mean blessing one of those
massive blessings the greatest blessing
in life is the capacity to bear and rear
children that is the it is literally how
the human species
exists it is how we move forward it is
the greatest the degradation of what
women are
by the left to well you know you're just
treating women as incubators no you are
treating women as incubators
i'm treating women as wholesome human
beings who have a magical superpower to
generate children
which is the greatest thing in life
honestly god i think that men should be
jealous of women that they get to do
this
you talk about god given gifts and
abilities
it's an un it's an unreal thing it's an
unreal thing having watched my wife be
pregnant three times give birth to three
of our to all three of our children
it is it is an experience unlike any
other and i'll tell you something my
wife who was
yeah she had real pregnancy morning
sickness and and she had a hard birth
the last couple of times
i can tell you she is grateful for every
moment of it including the pain because
we got the kids at the end of it
and because it's an unbelievable thing
the degradation of pregnancy to it's
just a bad thing that happened sort of
like a bad bowel movement is so
disgusting and dismissive of what women
are and what babies are it really is a
degradation of what life is
but this is
if if your view of humanity is that true
equality
is women have to give up what makes
women uniquely human
that women are that women should give up
what makes them uniquely human and that
any imposition
on on a on a woman such that she is not
allowed to kill her own child in the
womb
is somehow an undermining of her
autonomy then your perception of
autonomy is sick there's something
deeply wrong with your perception of
autonomy we're not talking about what
she can do with her own body we're
talking about what she can do with the
child inside her own body
camilla dry paul for her part was in
panic mode the progressive congresswoman
from washington state here she was
yesterday freaking out over the supreme
court
it was a devastating hearing for
millions of women across this country
for millions of people across this
country who are watching the supreme
court actually look like they are going
to overturn roe v wade and take us back
into the days of back alley abortions
this is personal to me i am one of the
one in four women in america who has had
an abortion it was a very difficult
choice for me to make but it was my
choice jose and that is what we need to
preserve for every person across the
country that has to be in that situation
um no that is not what we have to
preserve uh because
in no other area of
of life period do we say that your
choices with regard to other human
beings lives whether they get to be
preserved or not is your choice
the the fundamental position of the left
for for forever has been and and the
right by the way of any humane person
has been that you are not supposed to
other other types of human beings right
you're not supposed to say this group of
human beings is not fully human and
therefore we can treat them however we
want that is legitimately what the left
does with unborn human beings
they say this group of people are not
people they are not people so we can
flush them down a toilet
it is the greatest othering that is
possible to happen
and it's quite vile but pro-abortion
activists of course were very emotional
yesterday here were some of those
pro-abortion activists getting uh
getting upset yesterday
we'll be asking protesters on both sides
of the aisle what our country would look
like without roe v wade let's go see
what they have to say it'll look like
women going to jail a lot of women will
die
or they will be forced into a life of
poverty a lot of women are telling me
that women will die if rove is
overturned i think that's happening
already it's really scary because it
puts a lot of people in immediate
physical danger
and i just don't want to see that happen
it's putting women in physical danger to
give birth to babies as opposed to the
one hundred percent danger that is
presented by killing the child in the
womb that is one that there's not a risk
of danger for the child in the womb that
is a guarantee of death
okay in just a second we'll see how far
the left is willing to go here because
they are willing to go so far in pursuit
of abortion in pursuit of their equality
of outcome despite the baseline biology
it's incredible how far they're willing
to go they're now willing to basically
say that adoption is bad in order to
make an excuse for abortion we'll get to
that in just one moment first it is the
holidays you deserve a gift how about a
gift that keeps on giving you joy and
comfort every day all year long a gift
that looks as good as it feels a gift
that will actually pay for itself in
terms of how much more productive you
will be at work i'm talking about giving
yourself the gift of an ex chair i love
the x-chair let me tell you this thing
is supremely comfortable it is ergonomic
it it cools you down when you're when
you're too hot it heats you up when you
are too cold it gives you a massage
while you are sitting there they've got
that patented lmax technology the
doubles as the massage chair that can
either cool or warm at your back can
your office chair do any of these things
or does it just give you a back egg now
is the perfect time to purchase an
x-chair buy early and buy now you can
save a hundred bucks off your ex chair
just by purchasing it at
xchairshapiro.com right now that's the
letter x chair shapiro.com
s-h-a-p-i-r-o.com
x-chair has a 30-day guarantee of
complete comfort you can finance your
purchase for as little as 30 bucks a
month so really you have no risk right
pick it up see if you like it go to
xchairshapiro.com and save xchair
shapiro.com and again you can finance
that purchase for as little as 30 bucks
a month and get 100 bucks off your ex
chair today okay so how far is the left
willings go so they've already said that
sex and procreation are completely
separate a lie they've already said
that if you're not a woman you can't
have a perspective on abortion which
again is sort of akin to slave owners
saying that if you're not a slave owner
you can't have a perspective on
ownership of slaves
right slave owners saying to people in
the north listen you've never lived the
life of a slave owner so you don't know
what it's like to live with a slave you
don't know what the slaves actually want
no i pretty much do and they don't want
to be slaves how about that
and now you get to the the argument that
the leftists they've forced themselves
into a corner by embracing abortion as a
moral good
again their early argument which is that
abortion is tragic and sad and is
necessary on rare circumstances it's not
good enough for them and the reason it's
not good enough is because you can
legislate around that you'll take what
circumstances are we talking about and
then you can weigh as a legislative body
whether the circumstances we are
currently discussing
make some sort of excuse or
justification for abortion in particular
cases and whether there ought to be
legal dispensations for example for
abortion in cases where a mother's life
is in danger which pretty much all
pro-lifers agree there should be
okay but but because they want abortion
across the board like beginning to end
two points of birth in in the case of
ralph northam in virginia sometimes
beyond because that is what they want
out of this policy debate they then have
to downgrade all other possible choices
so we have to pretend number one that
contraception doesn't exist which of
course it does if you want to avoid
pregnancy i have a great pro-choice
position for you either one don't have
sex outside the bonds of marriage i know
this one is really passe i know we're
not allowed to talk about the fact that
premarital sex is actually not a morally
good thing okay that it is bad and it
creates bad risks and down and
down river risks in terms of getting
pregnant out of wedlock i know we're not
supposed to talk about that anymore
because it's super passe to talk about
baseline sexual morality in the society
but as somebody who did wait until
marriage to have sex and so did my wife
and now we have three beautiful children
within the context of a stable and
healthy marriage i can safely say
that the sacrifice
was was worth it because we have a
stable and healthy marriage with
beautiful children
okay but
that is one way that you downscale the
risk of pregnancy is don't have sex
outside of a context in which you are
okay having a baby
okay that is the number one way number
two we have birth control this also
downscales the risk of getting pregnant
tremendously you can do all of that
birth control is widely available you
can get birth control right now you can
go down to the local planned parenthood
they'll give you a pill they will give
you a condom you can go down your local
rite aid and do it too you don't have to
go to planned parenthood you know all of
those things so they have to downgrade
that they have to pretend those don't
exist the only option for women is
apparently to get pregnant and then use
the murder of the subsequent child as
the as the
for the backup form of birth control
okay but then there's another argument
right which the right makes correctly
which is well there is another option if
you don't want to have the baby in the
sense that you don't want to take care
of the baby you think that it's going to
ruin your life you think that you want
to pursue those 2 200 billable hours you
think you're too poor you think you
don't you have your life set up
there's another option and that is you
could not kill the kid and you could let
the kid be adopted
and this this option is taken by
literally hundreds of thousands of
people every year
and now the left has to downgrade that
that's how far they've gone in this
direction there's an absolutely
delusional and insane psychotic article
today from elizabeth spears who's a
democratic digital strategist it's
called i was adopted i know the trauma
it can inflict that's right the left is
so addicted to abortion that now they're
going to pretend that adoption is bad
that's how addicted to abortion they're
trying to remove all other possibilities
so no marriage
no birth control no abstinence before
marriage and now adoption is bad and
creates conflict here is elizabeth's
fears this is just psychotic crap it
truly is psychotic
on wednesday as the supreme court heard
oral arguments from state attorneys
seeking to uphold mississippi's 15-week
abortion ban just as amy coney barrett
kept getting it one question why was
abortion necessary when women who do not
want to be mothers can simply give up
their babies for adoption again this is
an op-ed in the new york times as an
adoptee myself i was floored by justice
barrett's assumption that adoption is an
accessible and desirable alternative for
women who find themselves unexpectedly
pregnant
she may not realize it but what she is
suggesting is that women don't need
access to abortion because they can
simply go do a thing that is infinitely
more difficult expensive dangerous and
potentially traumatic than terminating a
pregnancy during its early stages wait
hold on
more difficult dangerous and potentially
traumatic to whom
the entire left-wing position rests on
the complete dehumanization of a
pre-born child that's what it rests on
right oh it's so dehumanizing i mean
here we have an option where the kid
lives and just goes live goes to another
family that wants a baby or we have the
option of you stab it in the face
those are the two choices and you know i
gotta say it's really dehumanizing to
say that maybe the baby should live and
go to another family says elizabeth
spears
and this is she's writing as an adopted
kid
so how does she make that case because
if her mother had made that choice as
ronald reagan used to say
every
the the only pro-choice people who are
exist are people whose mothers chose
otherwise
right as an adoptive mother herself
justice barrett should have some inkling
of the complexities of adoption and the
toll it can inflict on children as well
as birth mothers but she speaks as if
adoption is some kind of idyllic fairy
tale my own adoption actually was what
many would consider idyllic i was raised
by two adoptive parents alice and terry
from the time i was an infinite infant
and grew up in a home where i knew every
day i was loved a few years ago i found
my biological mother maria and three
siblings i didn't know i had via dna
test in facebook
the first time i spoke to maria on the
phones has elizabeth spears she lives in
alabama not too far from my parents i
live in brooklyn she apologized
repeatedly for giving me up told me she
loved me and i was i would always be her
family your blood she would say later i
told her and continue to tell her every
time she brings it up the apology is
unnecessary i had a wonderful childhood
i believe she made the right decision
but she remains heartbroken about the
years we missed it together
okay so uh question she remains
heartbroken about the years we missed
together you know what years you missed
together had she chosen to flush you
down a toilet all of them there would be
no years together
and guess what her heartbreak over
giving you up for adoption
that is um that is a that is a side that
is a downside risk to the massive upside
of you being alive to write this op-ed
this is such insane stuff go get some
more of it in just one second first
let's talk about keeping your home safe
this holiday season detect the halls
walls windows and doors with the best
deals of the year on the award-winning
ring alarm
i'm sure we all know about the ring
video doorbell by now but did you know
that ring makes an award-winning alarm
ring alarm is a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself
so whether you are running across town
or across the country this busy season
you and your loved ones can rest easy
knowing your home is protected and it's
more than just security ring alarm
protects your home from flood freeze and
fire as well plus it is way cheaper than
the other companies for what they charge
for one month you can get an entire year
of ring alarm with professional
monitoring right now for the best deals
of the year on ring alarm go to ring.com
forward slash ben
we use ring alarm all the time at my
house that ring app comes in super handy
my son he now has one of these wobble
bikes where he sits around and he sits
on it and then he just moves around the
house really fast well um on occasion he
just disappears and i don't know where
he is and my son is uh liable to be
breaking the windows and setting things
on fire when he's in that sort of mood
and so i need to know where he is that's
where the ring app comes in handy so i
can stop him before he engages in acts
of physical destruction this holiday
season like the halls walls doors and
windows with the best deals of the year
on the award-winning ring alarm go to
ring.com forward slash ben get a great
deal on a ring alarm security kit today
that is ring.com forward slash ben okay
so back to this piece again in the new
york times about a woman who was adopted
but thinks adoption is not the is not
the option when it comes to adoption
versus abortion quote both maria and my
mom alice oppose abortion on religious
grounds my mom is white and southern
baptist maria is hispanic and
pentecostal both like to point to me to
justify their beliefs saying that had
maria gotten an abortion i would not
exist it's a familiar argument the
anti-abortion movement likes to invoke
nobel prize winners who might never have
materialized or potential adoptees who
might have cured cancer if they hadn't
been aborted at eight weeks
i'm no nobel prize winner but i still
resent being used as a political
football by the right i noticed that
you're here to resent it that's the
thing i noticed you're here to resent
being used as a political football
because you're not dead that's what it
was one of the things i noticed i
believe that abortion is a form of
health care and that every woman should
have access to it if she needs it oh do
you
i love these sorts of euphemisms i
believe that more than murder
is a form of cooking
like just fill in the blank with some
random
[Music]
completely bizarre non-sequitur
you yeah i believe that abortion is a
form of sport i believe that abortion is
a form of art i believe that abortion is
a form of calligraphy like what the
health care for whom not the person
you're killing
perhaps more than that i resent the
suggestion by people like justice
barrett that adoption is a simple
solution i resent it on behalf of maria
who found the choice she made
traumatizing and still feels that pain
44 years later even when an adoption
works out well as it did in my case it
is still fraud wait so let me get this
straight you are alive to resent the
adoption of you
on behalf of your mother who wanted to
give you up for adoption and is happy
she gave you up for adoption and feels
morally morally blessed that you are
alive and that she didn't murder you
but you resent that you are alive on
behalf of the mother who is happy to
keep you alive so that you could lead a
good life or you end up as a democratic
strategist pumping out garbage like this
for the new york times
uh uh honest to god this is like a
bizarre time loop from back to the
future too
in which you're alive to complain about
the fact that you are alive
when i echo maria and saying she gave me
up the language always wrangles adoptive
parents because it introduces an
unpleasant complexity
implying that my birth mother was not
completely happy with her choice or
worse that it made her miserable but
that is sometimes the case even when
adoption is the best option for all
involved adoption is not always an
unallowed good it's a complicated choice
in a situation that has no right or
wrong answer no no i found the wrong
answer it's killing you
that's it was it super hard
i feel like when the options are
woman can keep child
and struggle through the difficulties of
raising a child as say a single mom
or woman can give up child to a
two-parent family that is more
prosperous
and struggle with it with that decision
the choice that's bad is the one where
you just kill the kid that would be the
wrong choice
so you have two choices both of which
have some costs on a personal level and
both of which have some benefits but
both of which have a pretty major upside
which is that you didn't murder the kid
that's like
you understand the the insane moral
delusions you have to go through to come
to a pro-choice position via this
article and yet this is in the new york
times
if the court overturns roe versus white
says elizabeth spear in the new york
times many women will be forced to give
birth to children they did not want and
did not feel they could afford to
support well you know they they forced
to give
the language of force to give birth to
children is so bizarre it's so weird
again
forced to get pregnant is one thing
because typically we call that rape
right if somebody is forced to get
pregnant that is a grave moral sin
forced to give birth is you mean like
your body goes through the process that
normally happens when
you are when a baby is conceived
you're forced to give birth assumes
that there is
like another natural option there is no
the intervention is the termination of
the pregnancy
the it's sort of like saying water runs
downhill
okay and um so if you if you take water
and you put the top of a hill and it
goes to the bottom of the hill and i
don't stop that water from running
downhill the water was forced to reach
the bottom of the hill
no if you re-channel the water you're
performing the intervention
there's a massive logical fallacy right
here forced to give birth
nope that's the natural process
just as no one forces you to
have a digestive tract that processes
food you're not like what are we talking
about here
but this does go to the baseline idea
that there's a fundamental underlying
idea which is that biology is force
these folks believe that there is a
spirit in the machine and that any
threat to that spirit of autonomy
is an act of force
and must be defeated
this is what unites the pro-abortion
movement and the and the transgender
movement is the idea that biology is an
obstacle to your greatest dreams and to
your free-floating autonomy that is
disconnected from your biological
reality
but says elizabeth fears
while pregnant women will undergo the
bonding with a child that happens by
biological design as an embryo develops
into a living breathing conscious human
and then that child will be taken away
wait a sec hoba just hold up i swear
every sentence here is just a gem of
logical fallacy and insanity so she's
arguing against abortion let me read
those sentences again well pregnant
women will undergo the bonding with a
child that happens by biological design
as an embryo develops into a living
breathing conscious human and then that
child will be taken away
um not taken away you're giving up for
adoption
it's your decision you could keep the
child two you know what takes the child
away also
again i can't overstate this you know
what takes a child away and ends that
that bonding with the child
killing it
pretty good way of of ending that
bonding with the trap when i say you you
make it sound like adoption is
kidnapping
no
but i can tell you know what you what
when's that what ends the biological
design in which the embryo you you bond
with the embryo and the fetus
uh that would be death that ends that
biological design the right likes to
suggest that abortion is a traumatic
experience for women a last resort a
painful memory but adoption is often
just as traumatic as the right thinks
abortion is if not more so as a woman
has to relinquish not a lump of cells
but a fully formed baby she has lived
with for nine months
again
that's her decision as to whether she
wishes to give the baby up for adoption
but the the complete denial that there
is another character in this story is
the part that's truly galling i'm a
mother myself says elizabeth spears to
an adorable six-year-old self-proclaimed
fortnite expert and is often the case i
did not know i was pregnant with him
until the usual symptoms appeared a few
weeks into the pregnancy as anyone who
has just stated a human will tell you
that's a romantic way of talking about
pregnancy just stated a human
there's a vast difference between the
fourth week of pregnancy and the 40th by
the 40th you're familiar with your
baby's regular rhythms of kicking and
moving when i awoke my son would wake up
shortly after i'd feel him turning and
stretching or less pleasantly jamming
his precious little foot into what felt
like my cervix this is one of the
paradoxes of pregnancy something alien
is usurping your body and sapping you of
nutrition and energy but you're
programmed to gleefully enable it and
you become desperately protective of it
it's a kind of biological brainwashing
and this hop often happens whether you
want to be a parent or not right she's
just rebelling against biology she's
literally rebelling against biology my
my own biology is telling me i should
love my child damn you biology saying i
should love my unborn child inside my
womb growing and and learning to love me
how dare you biology this must be
stopped by the way i assume that she's
an abortion on demand fanatic which
means that even at the for she says
there's a difference between the fourth
week and the 40th week but i assume she
doesn't want any legislation to protect
the child at the 40th week
so um
no
but that that's that's so crazy i'm
sorry it's so crazy to describe
pregnancy as an experience where your
biology
takes over and forces you to love this
this mewling evil leech inside your butt
are there a lot of women who feel this
way about their kids
really i i've yet to meet one
i've yet to meet one who feels that the
child growing inside of her at week 30
when she feels the baby kicking and she
knows it's a baby that that is a leech
she she she loves it but she wishes she
didn't love it
my god
truly truly despicable stuff justice
barrett
says that says elizabeth spears is well
aware of the kind of biological
brainwashing that occurs during
biological brainwashing biological
brainwashing again the natural process
of pregnancy is not biological
brainwashing brainwashing implies force
it implies clockwork orange style i
strap you down to a chair and i force
you to watch propaganda
and that is not what we're talking about
biological brain do you mean the natural
process of childbirth she does
justice barrett is well aware of the
kind of biological brainwashing that
occurs during pregnancy she gave birth
to five children and yet she blithely
seems to assume that a mother can simply
choose not to bond with the child she's
just dating solely on the basis she's
not ready to be a mother or believe she
is unable to provide for the child
um
no you assume that because you assume
she can kill it
she assumes the mother will be supported
financially and otherwise throughout the
pregnancy even in a country where
maternal mortality statistics are
abysmal she assumes that children
surrendered for adoption will find a
home and not abet in the foster care
system no she doesn't assume any of
these things
adoption system should be revamped and
made better um but no
she probably assumes these things
because she cannot fathom being in this
position herself
uh it should be noted that justice
barrett has two adopted children
so um
you're a crazy person
these are assumptions that stem from the
privilege of being financially secure
having never needed an abortion and
perhaps the assumption that women who do
have something that that do have done
something wrong and must face the
consequences
um
well yes i do believe that women who
have abortion have done something
morally wrong yes that is true i that
that's the only part of this article i
agree with in my experience some on the
right believe that the trauma adoption
inflicts is a consequence of
irresponsibility but unexpected
pregnancy is not that's a fact a
function of bad decision-making
um
like 99
it is a function of bad decision making
it can be a failure of contraception
okay in which that's true sometimes
contraceptive fail which is why you
really shouldn't have sex outside of a
context in which you're willing to get
pregnant the product of a rape i know
that's super controversial
it's only controversial
in like the last couple of decades by
the way
like before that all of human history
the notion that you should only have sex
in context in which you are willing to
get pregnant that was a baseline moral
moral motion for literally all of human
history but now it's very controversial
it can be a failure of contraception the
product of a rape that's literally the
only circumstance that you can talk
about
by the way in which
it is legitimate in which pregnancy
literally has no relation to the to the
activity of the woman right is rape
which is why it's the most controversial
aspect of abortion law a mistaken belief
that a woman is infertile there is no
justifiable reason to inflict harm on
women and the babies they might produce
in any of these situations regardless of
judgment wait who's talking about
inflicting harm on babies
you you're talking about why a baby
shouldn't be adopted a baby should be
murdered that is what you are talking
about
the trauma doesn't just affect mothers
either
researchers have a term for what
children who are adopted even as infants
may suffer from later in life
relinquishment trauma
okay i have another term for what babies
may suffer in the womb when they're
killed and it's just called death so if
i have a choice between death and
relinquishment trauma i'm gonna go
relinquishment trauma we'll get to more
of this in a second
i go through this detail to demonstrate
just how far the left is willing to go
this is how far they are willing to go
abortion is so sacred to them it is such
a sacrosanct issue to them that they are
literally willing to say that it is
better for a baby to be
killed in the womb than to be given up
to a happy family for adoption
it's wild we'll get some more of it in
one second first if you own a business
you know there aren't enough hours in
the dates waste time playing phone tag
the list of customers you need to reach
does not get any shorter especially when
business is good that's why local
businesses everywhere turn to podium
podium makes every interaction as easy
as sending a text so everything that
makes your business great can get done
faster podium isn't just a better way to
communicate it's a better way to do
everything gathering reviews collecting
payments even marketing to your
customers podium makes it all as easy as
pressing send
you don't just free up more time you'll
grow your business and get more done
with podium you'll close deals with
customers before the competition even
has a chance to call them back join more
than 100 000 businesses that already use
podium to streamline their customer
interactions get started for free at
podium.com shapiro or sign up for a paid
podium account get a free credit card
reader restrictions apply that's
podium.com
shapiro again podium is a great way to
grow your business okay the fact is that
text is the best way to grow your
business if a business calls me on my
phone i'm not picking up if a business
texts me the chances that i respond if i
need to respond are like 100 use podium
make your business grow the way that it
should podium.com shapiro to get started
already we'll get to more on the
insanity of the pro-abortion crowd first
if you haven't picked up matt walsh's
best-selling new book i highly suggest
you change that the beloved children's
author sold out of that new book johnny
the walrus immediately after its release
but don't worry you can reserve your
copy at johnnyvelwalrus.com
get your hands on the next batch
shipping out soon johnny the walrus is
an exhilarating tale of a young boy who
pretends he's a walrus and it is all
pretend until the internet and mommy's
yoga class tell her that johnny is
actually a walrus and she must uphold
his trans walrus identity if you know
matt walsh you know this is hilarious
and you're going to laugh reading it to
your kids yourself or giving it to a
liberal friend and uh and exploding
their minds so head on over to
johnnythewalrus.com reserve your copy of
matt's timely masterpiece johnny the
walrus today also if you haven't already
you need to go check out our new merch
store over at dailywire.com shop while
you are there get your hands on a let's
go brandon trucker hat or a do not
comply t-shirt order now to get it in
time for christmas and get a sweet
discount on those daily wire original
collections that's dailywire.com
shop go check it out immediately we do
have ben shapiro show gear as well you
are listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so just to complete this
article from elizabeth spears because
the depths of delusion and insanity the
democrats are willing to go in order to
preserve abortion is totally crazy so
there's this article in the new york
times we're talking about in which she
argues that adoption is bad this is how
far they're willing to go in order to
preserve abortion adoption is now bad
it's the worst choice if you have a
choice between adoption and abortion you
should go for abortion according to
elizabeth spears who was adopted herself
quote researchers have a term for what
children who are adopted even as infants
may suffer from later in life
relinquishment trauma the premise is
that babies bond with their mothers in
utero and become familiar with their
behaviors when their first caregiver is
not the biological mother they register
the difference and the stress of it has
lasting effects
see um if you're separated from mommy
you get relinquishment trauma i'm sure
that's true you know what else causes
trauma
i know wait for it wait for it
being stabbed in the head
it's it's a trauma as it turns out being
injected in the heart with poison
a little traumatic
being flushed down a toilet these these
seem like
slightly more traumatic things than
relinquishment trauma
says elizabeth spear i probably got off
easy in that respect in part because i
did spend a few months with my
biological mother before i was adopted
but that had the unintended effect of
traumatizing my older siblings who
remember me as a baby who was there and
then suddenly was gone this was driven
home to me by my older sister bobby
whose first encounter with me was over
facebook all i can say is i remember you
she wrote and i have loved you and
missed you my entire life
as opposed to if you had been murdered
in which case you guys never would have
met at all what justice barrett and
others are suggesting women do in lieu
of abortion is not a small thing it is
life-changing irrevocable and not to be
taken lightly it often causes trauma
even when things work out it's a
disservice to adoptees and their
families biological and adopted to
pretend otherwise in service of a neat
political narrative nope again i think
that the neat political narrative is
that adoption in all of these cases is
better than killing somebody i know
so just to
repeat the left has now said
contraception is not enough you need to
be able to kill a baby in the womb
they've said that sex is not connected
to child bearing which of course is very
silly they've suggested that the actual
imposition is your biological process
taking place
they've suggested that adoption is a
worse option than abortion
all these things are things they are
willing to suggest in pursuit of an end
goal which is that men and women have to
be physically equivalent in every way
which is
unbelievably degrading to women it it
truly truly is
if this is the world that you want to
live in with the left then here's the
thing you you'll be able to live in this
world after rover's weight is gone all
you have to do is live in new york
all you have to do is live in california
you'll still be able to live in this
delusional crazy world and guess what
you will bear the consequences of living
in that sort of world
but at least fewer babies across the
country will have to suffer death at the
hands of people who believe these sorts
of delusional things
the the arguments that the left has been
forced to make in pursuit of their total
their totalitarian
anti-life position
truly astonishing astonishing stuff and
should be humiliating to them if they
had one ounce of humiliation left in
them these are shameful anti-human
arguments these are shameful immoral
arguments that are being made here and
they're taken as perfectly natural and
normal and in fact morally good by the
left i don't know how twisted you have
to be in order to believe that these are
morally good arguments
these are morally superior arguments and
the people who wish to preserve human
life are the baddies in this particular
scenario
alrighty meanwhile
kovitt has now reached new york
and i'm going to say co i mean oh macron
is in new york
now
i don't care the reason i don't care is
because again there is no doubt we would
have data by now by the way on
hospitalization and death
and uh there is no additional news that
this disease the omicron is likely to
provide additional hospitalization and
death it doesn't matter the media's
going to panic you anyway
so kathy hokel who is the the governor
of new york she inherited the office
after andrew cuomo could not keep his
hands off the asses of other women uh so
kathy hokel took over and now she has
declared that oh
macron is in new york everybody panic
everybody freak out
the information is still evolving but we
understand that this individual while
they were vaccinated they have very mild
symptoms and in fact those symptoms have
already resolved that is good news
and what we want to make sure we know is
that there is one way to address this
new yorkers
get vaccinated
get boosted
and get
ready and get ready i don't know what
you mean get ready get ready okay so
here's the thing the media have to freak
you out so the new york times runs a
piece today called prior infection is
little defense against virus variant
scientists say
evidence from south africa where the
omicron variant already dominates shows
a high rate of reinfection of people who
have already had the coronavirus okay so
um here's the question
that's true okay so the vaccines are not
stopping you from getting infected
i don't care
the reason i don't care is because every
year i get that flu vaccine and about
half the time i get the flu anyway
and that's because the flu vaccine
doesn't hit all the various strains
every year i get a cold i don't care
because it's just a cold and that's
called being a human and sometimes you
get sick the question is am i going to
have to go to the hospital and am i
going to die and if the answer is no to
either of those questions
don't care so there's a very long piece
in the new york times it is a very long
piece about how vaccines are not going
to protect you against oh macron and and
neither apparently will pass infection
quote a past coronavirus infection
appears to give little immunity to the
new omicron variant rippling across the
globe southern african scientists warned
on thursday potentially tearing away one
layer of defense humanity has won slowly
and at immense cost just a week after
its existence was revealed to the world
the heavily mutated variant which
scientists fear could be the most
contagious one yet is already by far the
dominant form of the virus in south
africa and spreading fast top european
disease experts said thursday it could
be the dominant form in europe within a
few months
scientists have known since early in the
pandemic the immunity gained from a
coronavirus infection is not total and
probably not permanent and some people
are reinfected
even so with a huge number of people
already infected and recovered about 260
million worldwide and in reality far
more according to experts whatever
protection they had looks like an
important layer in the world's defenses
the new variance the new variant calls
that into question
scientists in south africa have reported
a sudden sharp rise in november in
coveted cases among people in that
country who had already been infected
the authors noted there was no such
upswing when the beta and delta variants
emerge okay so i have a question
is it leading to more hospitalization
and death so let's do a quick search in
this article for the word
hospitalization nope does not appear
once how about death
nope does not appear once so basically
we're all supposed to panic because you
might get a disease that is less likely
to hospitalize or kill you according to
the data that we currently have
panic everyone
this is
they they lie because they say that
they're willing to understand the
reality
which is that zero covet is not going to
happen and that this will become an
endemic virus and in fact already is an
endemic virus and then the actual goal
that the media are pursuing is zero
covet because if you spend all day
worrying about getting covered
and getting sick for like three days and
not going into work and then being okay
i don't know what to tell you you are
living in crazy land
this is not stopping joe biden however
because again this all comes down to joe
biden's big promise that he was going to
stop covet he is not going to stop cove
but he doesn't have the ability to stop
cover because no politician has the
ability to stop coven i didn't blame
trump for that last year i'm not blaming
biden for it this year the only thing i
blame biden for is lying to the american
people that he was capable of stopping
cobit because he's not
but this is his new stick so president
biden is now
ushering in a bunch of new restrictions
he he announced yesterday by the way
that anthony fauci is the real president
which is frightening to i think everyone
or should be frightening to everyone
here was joe biden yesterday
i've seen more
of dr fauci that i have my wife we kid
each other but
uh they look who's president fauci
um but all kidding aside i i sincerely
mean it
so um yeah that uh all kidding aside he
means it fauci is the president which is
both very poorly for us considering that
that anthony fauci is wild and crazy and
self-conflicting on all of this stuff
and highly political by the way anthony
fauci came out yesterday and he said
that fully vaxxed americans with
boosters are still going to need to wear
masks so basically mask up until the end
of time literally until the end of time
everyone's been talking about
what to do if you're unvaccinated or
without a booster but what should
someone who has all three shots do to
protect themselves against the omacron
variant
what you do is exactly what we were
saying and that is to be prudent and
careful and one of the things that's
very clear
is that you if you have to be
in an indoor congregate setting in which
you're unsure of what the vaccination
statuses of the people around you wear a
mask
okay so um you're fully boosted you're
fully vaxxed you should still be wearing
a mask according to anthony fauci until
the end of time until the end of time so
joe biden has put out a new plan what
exactly is his new plan it includes
hundreds of vaccination sites boosters
for all adults new testing requirements
for international travelers and free at
home tests
none of this is going to stop covered
the reason it's not going to stop
covered is because there are lots of
people who don't want to get vaccinated
even the vaccinated are still passing
this to other vaccinated people by the
way and um and boosters are not
necessary for all adults okay the the
the cdc ruling is contradicted by the
who what the data tend to show is that
if you're over the age of 60 you
probably should get a booster because
the immunity to hospitalization and
death begins to wane from the 90 down to
the 70 but if you're 30 and you're
healthy then your immunity in terms of
hospitalization and death is pretty
durable you're talking about a very
marginal increase for the price of a
booster shot
literally i had my physical yesterday
talk to the doctor about it this is what
he told me confirming what i already
knew obviously what i've been talking
about on the show every single day
the we are at the end of this thing
and people who live in red states know
this because we have been living
normally for a long time it's hanukkah
i've been going to hanukkah events and
everybody's unmasked and no one cares
and guess what we here in florida we
have the lowest transmission rates in
america
so
i don't tell you but the left is they
are addicted they are addicted to the
restrictions they're not even addicted
to anything remotely like a solution
they're just addicted to the idea that
they have a solution
so now you have
you have msnbc's dr red laner suggesting
that anthony valkyrie should literally
ban people who are unvaccinated from
flying again airplanes are not the
vector of transmission we know this it
doesn't matter it's just about the
control at this point
there's a couple of more tools
in our quiver here which include for
example and which something i've been
advocating for which is i don't think
anyone
should be allowed on an airplane
domestic or international or trained
without being able to prove they've been
vaccinated to me that's really the only
way in addition to testing that we're
going to get better control over the
situation we currently have nicole
more restrictions more restrictions more
restrictions meanwhile gensake is saying
nothing is off the table from the from
the white house press office here she is
why not go further in the direction of
of you know public health and mandates
given the potential risk and the fact
that we're headed into winter sure well
one i would say that um nothing is off
the table um so an uh including domestic
travel
oh nothing nothing is off the table by
the way the economy is reacting
just as you would expect it to people in
the economy are not afraid of kovat
they're afraid of the reaction to covey
jp morgan said as much yesterday and the
media are pressing this forward so joy
reid was just freaking out about this
yesterday because it's a day ending and
why andrea reed has to freak out about
something so here she was uh with uh
with the surgeon general freaking out
over over oh macron by the way five
confirmed cases of omicron in new york
all of them alive
i have to say so far the most
embarrassing thing about omicron is that
the person who apparently spread it in
new york was at an anime convention
how would you like that to be your day
you're revealed as patient zero in new
york and um and that's not the most
embarrassing thing about you it's that
you're in an anime convention here is
here's joy read yesterday
let's talk about omicron
my adult children live in new york they
they've been screenshotting and sending
me if info on omicron it's really
frightening because it feels like it is
the next sort of wave of the pandemic
and it it feels kind of unstoppable how
much more dangerous is the omicron
variant than delta
okay and the answer is they have no idea
because there's no data suggesting that
it is more dangerous than delta in fact
there's some data suggesting it's less
dangerous than delta
yeah but i i also like that people are
are they they're she says they're
screenshotting i'm confused as how you
screenshot omicron how does that work
andrew ross sorkin who has been
extraordinarily uh valuable about his
fears regarding kovid despite the fact
that again he's vast his wife is back
from i think he's talked about this on
air um and his kids are very young which
means they're fine uh he was freaking
out about this yesterday as well
the constitution does still exist
despite the headwinds that we've had in
the last two years and the encroachments
on the constitution it still does exist
so that we do have rights it's the first
amendment the tenth amendment uh
protecting us against federal
governments
and and and the reality is kill my
mother
the rights are that you can they're
right right
i'm not killing your mother
and if she has the vaccine those risks
are mitigated and we're seeing that
in most likely cases your your mother
will not die if she's vaccinated
you don't have the right to kill my
mother honestly if this is the way that
the left is going to be living in a
society then we're all in real trouble
here because it turns out that if your
mom is elderly and immunocompromised
then we all have to wear masks at all
times and not cloth masks can 95 masks
because i could give your mom the flu
and your mom could die the flu lots of
old people die the flu every single year
every single year
okay so because of the left's maintained
delusion that they can control kovid the
economy is just it's stagnating
there's a brand new jobs report out for
november massive miss massive miss on
the jobs report
the jobs report apparently shows that we
added about 210 000 jobs in november the
forecast was for wait for it 570 000
jobs
so they missed by 360 000 jobs last
month
they're missing month after month after
month the entire trajectory of the
american economy is wrong because of
this administration the inflation is
happening because of this administration
people are not going back to work people
are staying out of the workforce
there are more open jobs right now than
there are people able to fill those open
jobs
we are sinking into the possibility of
an actual honest-to-god recession in a
time when we should have a massive
economic boom going on like the economy
is not supposed to be stagnating right
now the economy is supposed to be
booming right now you're not supposed to
get 210 000 jobs added in a time when
we've only gained back 83 of the jobs
that were lost in the first place
this is wild and crazy okay but the dccc
has to bl they have to brag about
something by the way
let me just note how much of a failure
these policies are by the way when we
talk about jobs being added
complete failure the wall street journal
reports the unemployment rate in october
hit the lowest on record since 1976 in
west virginia georgia oklahoma utah
nebraska vermont idaho south dakota new
hampshire alabama montana wisconsin and
indiana
um i've noticed that all of those places
are red
all of them
meanwhile the states that have a massive
unemployment rate california nevada new
jersey new york new mexico connecticut
hawaii michigan and alaska all have
democratic government trifectas except
for michigan which has a gop legislature
and alaska which is red
and as far as regaining jobs
if the states that have regained jobs at
the fastest clip are all red the states
that have not regained jobs are all blue
so the bind administration has to come
up with some sort of narrative as to how
they're fixing this thing uh and they
came up with this chart and this chart
is just glorious because i have to take
a moment to just admire the incredible
stupidity of the democratic
congressional campaign committee that
put this together
the dccc so they tweeted out thanks joe
biden and they put out a chart about gas
prices now where did they get this chart
about gas prices they got it from matt
iglesias so matt iglesias who now writes
over at sub stack he's a left-leaning
guy he put out a
mocking he put out a chart mocking the
biden administration's
push for the notion that they've curbed
inflation and the chart that he put out
showed that over the course of the last
couple of weeks the price of gas had
gone down on average by two cents and it
was supposed to be mocking them for
their talking about so the dccc took it
seriously and they turned it into a
chart i just want to note the the
incredible just
every aspect of this chart is glorious
so it says u.s regular all gas all
formulations gas price
okay and it shows on the y-axis dollars
per gallon and on the x-axis it shows
the date now only two dates shown
november 12 november 22nd 2021 november
29th 2021
okay and then in the dollars per gallon
it shows a range of
3.415 to 3.375
so now you're saying yourself wait so
you're talking about the difference
between like the entire y-axis right the
entire possible differential is between
a gas price of 341 a gallon and 338 a
gallon
it's a three it's a that's a three to
four cent spread is what you're talking
about right now about a three and a half
cent spread
so they make the y axis super large
right so every increment on the y axis
is really big so the chart looks as
though if you decreased from 3.415 per
gallon to 3.410 per gallon that'd be
like a massive decrease okay so in
reality the chart shows that the price
of gas has decreased by about two cents
okay and then that's not enough they
didn't just stretch the y-axis so that
it looks so they can pretend that there
was an actual gas price decrease that is
meaningful for people
they also put an arrow at the end of u.s
regular all formulations gas price and
the arrow looks like frankly in a
drooping arrow which says something
about biden harris it is a drooping
arrow it takes a sharp 90 degree
downturn because this is how steeply the
prices are decreasing
okay now
this chart like this is the best you do
they were doing this in july right your
your july 4th meal is going to be 16
cents cheaper this year and then by
thanksgiving it's gonna be like a lot
more expensive you won't get a turkey
but we are doing the job we over here at
the dccc we're doing the job by the way
just to show you how how crazy this
chart is
here's another chart this chart is a
chart of the actual
inflation in the gas price over the last
18 months
so basically since november of 2020
beginning november 20th
you're looking at a gas price on average
of about
two dollars and 13 cents a gallon
somewhere in that neighborhood then you
have a consistent and steep rise all the
way up to three bucks and 42 cents
and so the dccc
featured heart showing the last two
weeks in which the average price of gas
is decreased from 340 to 338 and like
we're fixing this thing
weird because uh when joe biden took
office the average price of gas was a
little under 240 a gallon now it is 340
a gallon and um and you are showing me
like the last two weeks
they got nothing guys they have nothing
they have nothing they have a doddering
old president who doesn't know how to
handle this thing and who's just going
to keep throwing restrictive measures at
the american people and all that's going
to do is sink the economy but at least
at least she's with it at least he's not
you know routinely slurring his words
oh
wait no he's actually routinely slurring
his words my bad here he was yesterday
slurring his words
these teams work
they provide needed staff for staff
overruns
badly needed staff where overrun
hospitals are handling more patients
than they can
they can handle for their emergency
rooms and intensive care units who don't
have a personnel available
they help provide life-saving treatments
in communities in need like monoclonal
antibody treatments
we have over 20 teams deployed now
today i'm announcing that we're going to
triple that more than double we're going
to get to 60 teams ready to deploy in
states experience the surging cases over
the course of this winter
[Music]
is he speaking english anymore
i i i have doubts
by the way how delusional is joe biden
yesterday he explained that during the
six day war he met golden mayor in
israel there are only about eight
problems with this particular story here
he was delivering another one of his
just false stories
many times i've been to israel i said
not all of a sudden i realized god
you're getting old but
i have known every
every prime minister well
since golda meir including gold in my
ear
he said that he visited israel during
the six day war
there's a problem with that golden mayor
was not the prime minister of israel
during the six day war she was prime
minister of israel during the during the
1973 yom kippur war and also joe biden
was in law school during the six day war
so yeah
uh do you feel steady leadership you
feel that hand on the tiller of state
you feel like we have this return to
normalcy
can you feel it can you feel it or are
we just abjectly screwed alrighty we
will be back here a little bit later
today with an additional hour of content
first you can't forget to end your week
by checking out the andrew clavin show
drew shows every friday as always he has
an exciting evening planned for you so
head on over to dailywire.com 7 pm
eastern 6 pm central tune in i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin